Merhaba sevgili öğrenciler. Kanalıma hoş
geldiniz. Yeni müfredatla, yepyeni
konularla yine her zamanki gibi
karşınızdayız. Milli Eğitim
Bakanlığı'nın sizin için hazırlamış
olduğu yeni müfredatı en ince
ayrıntısına kadar ünite ünite birlikte
işleyeceğiz. Bu müfredattaki ilk ünite
School Life yani okul hayatı. Bu
ünitedeki önemli kelimeleri gördükten
sonra önemli dil bilgisi kurallarını ve
kalıplarını hep birlikte teker teker
inceleyeceğiz.
Kalem ve kağıdınız hazırsa dersimize
başlıyoruz. Countries and nationalities.
Ülkeler ve milletler. Ülkelerin ve
milletlerin İngilizce isimlerini hep
birlikte öğreneceğiz.
Friends, Fransa, French, Fransız.
Italy, İtalya
Italian, İtalyan.
Japan, Japonya Japanese Japon, Spain,
İspanya Spanish, İspanyol Germany
Almanya German, Alman
Korea, Korean
Koreli.
Norway, Norveç. Norwegian, Norveçli.
Bulgeria,
Bulgaristan.
Bulgarian
Bulgar
Mexico, Meksika Mexican Meksikalı
Ukraine Ukrayna
Ukrainian
Ukraynalı
Poland Polonya Polis Polonyalı
Scotland
İskoçya Skadiş İskutth
Africa, Güney Afrika South African Güney
Afrikalı Hungar Macaristan
Hungarian
Macar.
Ülkeler ve milliyetlerle ilgili bir
diyalog inceleyelim. Genellikle
milliyetler ve konuşulan diller aynıdır.
Mesela Spanish İspanyoldur. Spanish aynı
zamanda konuşulan dildir. Bu her ülke
için geçerli değildir ama çoğunlukla
aynı şey geçerli olur. Hi there, Alex
from Spain. Merhaba, ben İspanya'dan
Alex. Nice to meet you, Alex. John
and from
nationality and what languages do speak.
Tanıştığıma memnun oldum Alex. Ben John
ve ben Fransa'danım.
Hangi dili konuşuyorsun ve milliyetin
nedir? Great to meet you. Spanish and
I can speak Spanish, French and English.
Seninle tanışmak harika. Ben İspanyolum.
İspanyolca, Fransızca ve İngilizce
konuşurum. I Mexican and I can speak
Spanish and English. Ben Meksikalıyım.
Ben İngilizce ve İspanyolca
konuşabilirim. Important words önemli
kelimeler demektir. Bu ünitede bulunan
ve bilmeniz gereken diğer önemli
kelimeler şunlardır. Capital, başkent.
Take a trip seyahate çıkmak.
Castle, kale.
Palace saray
tower. Kule.
Visit. Ziyaret etmek.
Visitor ziyaretçi.
Travel seyahat etmek traditional
geleneksel.
Explore keşfetmek
Ancient Museum Antik Müze.
Historical Site Tarihi Kent
Art Museum Sanat Müzesi.
Journey Yolculuk Seyahat
Sing. Gezip görme.
Tourist attraction turistlik yerler
vlogger.
Video çeken kişi.
Local food, yerel yiyecekler.
Destination varış yeri, natural beauty.
Doğal güzellik.
Cultural activities
kültürel aktiviteler.
Natural wonder doğa harikası mud
volcanos, çamur volkanları
hotprings, sıcak kaplıcalar.
Unique Art, eşsiz sanat.
Historical wonders tarihi harikalar.
Arkitecture.
Mimari
Sky Scrapper. Gökdelen.
Peaceful barışçıl huzurlu.
Cuine yerel mutfak
cultural exchange
kültürel değişim
wording görmeye değer. Experience
deneyim
monument abide anıt.
Sandmark, sembol yapı. Curious meraklı
ruin. Harabe.
Magnificent
muhteşem.
Delicious lezzetli
various
çeşitli.
Enormo kocaman büyük.
Lake. Göl. Glacier. Buzul.
Forest. Orman. Scenery
manzara
river neh adventure macera
valley vadi climate iklim
population
nüfus
ancestor ata
diverse çeşitli social language sosyal
dil demektir. Wintede kullanılan
kalıplar şunlardır.
Birine selam vermek istiyorsanız hello,
hi ya da hi there diyebilirsiniz.
Let me introduce myself. Kendimi
tanıtmama izin ver lütfen. This is
Yasemin from Türkiye. Ben Türkiye'den
Yasemin. Eğer bir yer hakkında fikrinizi
belirtecekseniz wow ifadesini
kullanabilirsiniz. This palace tower ya
da buna benzer yerler is great. Bu yer
harika, muhteşem diyebilirsiniz.
Let's grab our trays. Hadi tepsimizi
alalım. Chat about bir şey hakkında
konuşmak demektir. Noktalara konuşmak
istediğiniz herhangi bir konuyu
koyabilirsiniz.
İngilizcenin temel yapılarından bir
tanesi olan to be ifadelerini
işleyeceğiz. To be kalıbı nesneleri ve
insanları nitelendirirken kullandığımız
temel yapılardan bir tanesidir.
Kullanımları oldukça kolay. I öznesi ile
birlikte kullanılır. He, she ve it
öznesi ile birlikte is kullanılır.
Bunları kısa yazmak da mümkündür.
Örneğin he, she ve it öznesini yazdıktan
sonra kesme işareti kullanıp s takısını
ekleyebiliriz. Böylece he is ifadesini
kısaltmış oluyoruz. We, you ve they'den
sonra ise are yardımcı ekini kullanırız.
Bunu kısaltmak da mümkündür. Özneleri
yazdıktan sonra kesme işareti kullanır.
R ve E harfini yazarız. Örnekleri
inceleyelim.
Bunlar nesneler ve insanlar için
kullanılır. I an engineer. Ben bir
mühendisim. I özesi ile birlikte
kullanılır. She is from Italy. O
İtalya'dan she kız özesi ile birlikte is
kullanılır. Kerem is tallim. Kerem uzun
ve zayıftır. Kerem telemek için erkek
olduğundan dolayı is kullandık. We are
in the kitchen. Biz mutfaktayız. We
öznesi ile birlikte yardımcı ek olarak
are kullanırız. Eğer to be ifadesini
olumsuz yani negatif olarak kullanmak
istiyorsak şu şekilde kullanabiliriz.
I özdesi ile birlikte yanına ise not
yazarız. Bunlar birleşik bir şekilde
yazılmazlar. Ayrı ayrı kullanılırlar.
not olumsuz bir ifadedir. He, she ve
itesi ile birlikte to be fiilini olumsuz
yapacaksak bunu is, not şeklinde uzun
olarak yazabiliriz ya da isn't şeklinde
kısa olarak yazarız. Genelde kısa şekli
tercih edilir. Geriye kalan öznelerde
ise yani we, you ve they öznesinde
yardımcı ek olarak are kullanırız. Eğer
olumsuz yapacaksak not ekleriz. Kısa
haliyle arzır.
Örnekleri inceleyelim. I not very
tired. Ben çok yorgun değilim. I
özlüsünden sonra kullandık. Olumsuz
yapabilmek için not'ı yanına ekledik.
Ömer isn't my brother. Ömer benim erkek
kardeşim değildir. Ömer erkek özesi
olduğu için is kullandık. Olumsuz
yapabilmek için not ekledik. İngilizcede
en çok karşınıza çıkacak olan ve en sık
kullanılan kalıplardan bir tanesi olan
ken ifadesini işleyeceğiz. Ken'in
cümlelerde çeşitli görevleri var.
Bunları teker teker inceleyelim.
Ken yapısını becerilerimizden ve
yeteneklerimizden bahsederken
kullanabiliriz. Ayrıca bu yapıyı
olasılıklar, ihtimallerden bahsederken
de kullanabiliriz.
Şimdi ya da gelecekte olabilecek olan
bir ihtimal için kullanılır. Son olarak
ken yapısını opportunity için yani
fırsat ve izinlerde kullanabiliriz.
İlk olarak beceri ve yeteneklerde
kullanılan keni inceleyelim.
Cümlelere ebilmek anlamı katar. I can
swim. Ben yüzebilirim. Benim böyle bir
yeteneğim, böyle bir kabiliyetim var.
Bunu yapabiliyorum. She can speak
English. O İngilizce konuşabilir. Böyle
bir yeteneği kabiliyeti var.
They can play the piano. Onlar piyano
çalabilirler.
Gördüğünüz gibi can kelimesi hiçbir
özneye göre değişmez. Her özne can
olarak kullanılır. Herhangi bir
eklemenize gerek yoktur. İkinci olarak
can yapısı ihtimallerden bahsettiğimizde
kullandığımız bir yapıdır dedik.
It can be very hot in summer. Yazın çok
fazla sıcak olabilir. Bu bir ihtimal.
Bundan bahsederken can kelimesini
kullanabiliriz.
Acidents can happen. Kazalar olabilir.
Bunlar ihtimal dahilinde.
This rod can be dangerous. Bu yol
tehlikeli olabilir. Böyle bir ihtimal
var. Bu yüzden burada can
kullanabiliriz.
Can yapısının 3üncü işlevi ise fırsatlar
ve izinlerdir.
Eğer karşımıza çıkan bir fırsattan ya da
herhangi bir şey için izin alırken can
kullanabiliriz.
You can brow my book. Benim kitabıma
ödünç alabilirsin. Karşıdaki insana izin
veriyoruz. We can go to the park. Parka
gidebiliriz.
Students can join the club. Öğrenciler
kulübe katılabilirler.
Can kelimesinin olumsuz hali yani
negatif hali can't olarak kullanılır.
Eğer cümleleri olumsuz yapacaksak,
beceremiyorum, yapamıyorum ya da izin
vermiyorum tarzı anlamlarda
kullanacaksak can't yapısını
kullanabiliriz.
I can't ride a horse. Ben ata binemem.
Böyle bir becerim, böyle bir yeteneğim
yok.
She can't be only 10 years old. O sadece
10 yaşında olamaz. Böyle bir ihtimal söz
konusu değildir.
You can't eat in the library. Sen
kütüphanede bir şeyler yiyemezsin.
Buna izin yok, yapamazsın. Burada da
kent kullanabilirsiniz. Beni
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.